a rate conversion like this is really
just a pair of unit conversions that are
happening together so if you remember
all those bits really like convert bills
two leaders and convert days to use or
whatever it is you're just doing a pair
of them simultaneously okay now we're
just caught before we actually start
doing this that you probably use your
calculator for the vast majority of it
and that's totally okay however wherever
you can avoid it and do some it's me
that you can't say enough I think that's
smart number one because it sort of
flexes your muscles and makes you
quicker at these and more efficient
market and secondly your calculator is a
great tool right but if you don't use it
properly it's just a tool and it will
give you the Royal heads up because it's
giving you the right answer so the real
question okay so you have to be very
careful how you use it and if we can do
this without a twitch in fact for this
particular question you can you're going
to be much more an advantage so here's
the way we're going to begin you start
with the rate that they give you and
then you think okay I need to get to
hear so the first thing is am I going to
spoil the unit's am I going to bigger
units in this case I've got a smaller
units so all these numbers are going to
get larger the units are small so you
got lots of them does that make sense so
in order to help me do that i'm going to
write this as a proper fraction because
people often get confused right when
they sort of tried to all into one line
so I've written it as a proper fraction
and I've also said per day is for one
day right there's actually a number in
playa so now I can start to climb down
and smiling to spoil you this okay and
some Freeman and I'm going to go down as
far as I need to until I hit the units
that I'm actually after ok so in the
case of the numerator that's really easy
how many grams are there in seven point
two kilos it's going to be seven
thousand two hundred grams so that's
really good I've already done like I've
already eaten this unit that's fantastic
but for the next one like I don't know
about you but I don't have memorized the
number of minutes there are today so
I've got to go down a couple of steps
what's the next step after date hours
right so there are 24 hours ok now
what's really helpful here is rather
than like continue
make it up as a bigger right because
they will get figure as soon as I've
written this I see I could do some
simplifying right 72 / 24 that's a quite
a nice car model actually it's just
going to be three okay so 300 grams is
what I've moved eaten consumed within
one hour does that make sense you see
I've divided everything by 24 and then I
just climbed down one more step that
will get me to the one on actually one
yes so 300 grams per how many minutes 60
and so you can see I can cancel one more
time 309 over 60 years or your unit
upside down yeah so I can think about
okay cancel cancel some zeros and then
I've got 30 / 600 630 there are fine
with it right so now that I've got the
final answer 5 grams per there's only
one minute left on the bottom so i just
say five guys for you okay so if you
don't have such nice numbers at some
point here you're going to reach for you
Caffrey on like if it was 30 / 7 say
that or you can see the fraction right
but in this case stuff you find you get
nice numbers like this very frequently
because we're trying to see like dealing
with icky numbers is not what we're
trying to focus on that's not the skill
that we're after the skill or after is I
can you understand how these you this
relate to each other and then sort of
climb down ladder or climb up if I go in
bigger units okay so that's the
important bit and the numbers are less
of an issue so when you get to the
conversions this is the way I'd set it
out don't don't skip over like all of
these units they're important theme
right so don't just write numbers